i know i had a few moments in my career
where when i got on the sideline too i i
reevaluated myself to go like why am i
making this so hard like like this is
i'm watching this guy throw to wide-open
receivers what what the hell am i doing
exactly and did you have that moment oh
yeah yeah yeah and that's i mean
especially when d.a came in and just
kind of seeing how he operated how he
watched film his thought process when a
play happened and even small things that
come into a walk-through and how precise
he was
where he was trying to put the ball
where he wanted in walk throughs and was
actually throwing it and like making it
practice like right i know sometimes the
receivers don't like that when they're
kind of walking and the ball is coming a
little fast but even small little
details like that just trying to be
precise all all the time that helped out
for me right receivers complaining on
walkthroughs that you're throwing the
ball too hard i've heard that story
before yep yeah but that's what they got
to get used to all right so i'm going to
walk over to you because i want to ask
you something
one one thing i always want to ask guys
how they grip the ball i'm always
interested to see that
if you want to get a close-up on his
hand
you're two and under five yep always did
that
always always oh wait what'd you just do
there will you just make sure i got a
little air pocket so you're there you're
into this i'm not a flat
flat i'm a flat hander really i am a
flat hander yeah i don't know why but i
just always use a flathead so is your
thumb a little higher or is it still i
have a flexible thumb to where like i
can i have a double jointed thumb
hitchhiker's thumb i know that it's not
known i do not have that but who's got
the more displacement
the hitchhiker or the double jointed guy
chris sims both a flat hander and a flat
earther with josh allen earlier this
week in buffalo the entire interview
will be available next week chris sims
unbuttoned now you said yesterday that
you had a catch with josh allen i didn't
see any catching going on by either you
or josh allen yeah well no we're
quarterbacks we don't we don't get our
hands beat up catching the football
i'm a pampered i'm a diva i need
somebody there i wasn't catching his
footballs first of all um you want to
talk about watching a ball explode out
of a guy's hand mike i mean it's a
special arm this kid has and it was a
lot of fun hanging out with them the
other day
well and i think part of the thing too
if two quarterbacks are throwing and
catching if one puts a little something
extra on it and you feel it then the
reaction is i'm going to put a little
second okay the next thing you know
you're firing the ball at each other's
heads no doubt about that exactly which
would have made for a much better clip
it would have well the clip was good
that would have been better well we we
had a great we had a great conversation
i mean really that clip goes on for
another probably 15 or 20 minutes we do
end up having a little throwing
competition okay i'm not going to give
the spoiler alert out but yeah we talked
we got back together a few times went
over some nuances of what was going on
at the quarterback position and
everything but you know i'm a big fan of
him mike and i'm a big fan of the
buffalo bills and what they're doing up
there right now
the big surprise last year too the
mobility of josh allen with three at
minnesota diving for the pylon hurtling
anthony barr
and and just showing uh something that
you know it's not that it's a secret
that the guy had some mobility we were
just so worried about passing accuracy
and and the deep ball and can he throw
it you know to the open guy uh on a
consistent basis but but i think he did
enough
to make me think there's something there
yes and i think the bills are doing
enough to make me think there's
something there vegas doesn't believe
vegas has the over under for wins at six
and a half i i got more faith in the
buffalo bills than that chris
and i think that they can make some
noise this year between them and the
jets i think one of them is going to
rise up and be a playoff team i just
don't know which one at this point but i
think both teams will at least be in
that conversation to be 500 uh 100 agree
with you mike and again first of all
buffalo let's let's let's get this
straight their defense was one of the
best in football last year i would argue
it was the best in football but they had
offensive struggles that put the defense
in some tough spots okay so i look at
that and go wow the defense isn't going
anywhere and they got ed oliver okay so
that's phenomenal but really the big
thing they did in the offseason and i'm
with you on josh allen obviously yeah
the short passing game accuracy can
improve but that's something that can be
worked on and improved but the big thing
is improve the offensive line got mitch
morse the best center in football and
free agency drafted a cody ford you know
got some tai niseki a tackle from the
washington redskins was a great move and
then got the new england d-type
receivers and john brown and cole
beasley to be those guys because they're
running the new england offense to run
all those option jerk routes so i think
they have formulated the right pieces
now that fit the system on both sides of
the ball and usually when i see that
together i go oh that means something
good's about to happen and i'm with you
i think they're a you know play-off on
the edge of a playoff type football team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports